all right Ross Tucker the Ross Tucker
football podcast is available Ross on
the sidelines for Westwood One coverage
of the Jets and lions last night and he
joins us on the program I was talking a
while ago in fact in the first hour that
maybe Matthew Stafford is the Carmelo
Anthony of the NFL a lot of stats but
nothing really to show for it as far as
playoff resume what do you think of that
wow that's an interesting comparison I
never thought of that before I don't
think so
I think that I think Stafford has never
really had a great team around him I
understand the comparison and I think
it's fair but I also think he's got a
ways to go in his career but last night
was rough you're right I mean he was
getting getting beat up his
interceptions were awful it was really
really surprising because you know the
new head coach Dan we know you know Matt
Patricia is on the defensive side of the
ball and he's changing things up but
they had the same offensive coaches it's
still Jim Bob cooter and they've
invested so much in an offensive line I
mean really the only bright spot for the
Lions in the entire game was Kenny
Galilei you know they're they're young
receiver he was about the only thing
that they can really hold on to that
that's interesting comparison I'm gonna
say no because I feel like over the last
few years
Stafford has continued to get better
we'll see how this year goes by feeling
the last three to four years he's gotten
better every year
the Jets announced after the game that
they knew the signals they knew
everything that Stafford was doing they
said they did their preparation but but
how does that work and why are you
announcing that you knew what he was
going to do with the line of scrimmage
yeah I don't really understand that I
don't know how it works that they had
such a good feel for it you know it's
the first game of the year so they might
have been able to spend a lot of time
going over the coaching copy and the TV
copy and really doing everything they
could to dissect Stafford's hand signals
which by the way it's totally legal the
only thing you can
do is you can't have a camera down on
the sidelines just focus on the
defensive coordinator or the offensive
coordinator but you can absolutely look
at the TV can I talk to coach the whole
time they have young guys on the staff
of that I mean even college they do that
they have those guys go back over the TV
copy and even you know how quarterbacks
from Mike now all the time Dan they'll
have the the quarterbacks Mike they'll
have them go back and listen to every
check the guy makes see what happens and
they've gotten very very good at it and
it did seem like the Jets had a pretty
good beat on it last night
certainly Darrin Lee but I don't know
why anybody would ever come out and say
that you don't benefit from that anyway
it's all I mean you as a player Dan it's
like why would you give it credit to the
coaches you're almost a given except of
the coaches rather than yourself but
Ross you have a whole new coaching staff
you would think you would have different
signals for Matthew Stafford and said
unless Stafford says to Matt Patricia
hey these these are my signals or these
are my audibles or whatever so the the
Jets can look at tape but wouldn't you
have a new set of signals audibles there
well maybe but you remember you know
Patricia it's interesting when he came
in he brought in his own defensive staff
but he kept almost the whole offensive
staff including Jim Bob cooter so they
might have said hey let's stick what
stick with what works it's going well
for us and obviously that backfired
usually teams change it up because you
know other teams are trying to examine
it especially when there's a whole
offseason and especially also Dan in the
NFL there's so much movement from the
players from team the team you never
know which guy that was on your team
goes somewhere else I can tell you right
now when I got cut by the Redskins and
went to the Cowboys the next day on
waivers the first thing I did was sit
down with Jim Jeffcoat the d-line coach
and Mike Zimmer the defensive
coordinator and tell them all the
Redskins signals and all the all the
audibles that I knew about that's the
first thing to do so you better be
changing them up if you're not you're
not doing your job as a coaching staff
he's Ross Tucker he's on the sidelines
last night Jets Lions
working for Westwood One when Stata when
Sam Donald throws that pick six what's
it like on the sidelines when he comes
back over oh my goodness Stan I was on
the jet sideline I was right there I was
actually like ten yards from Sam when he
threw that and four more hours looking I
thought oh man that guy's wide open this
is looking good and you realize you
realize how hard it is to be a
quarterback you know he had just stepped
up in the pocket and he scramble to get
up and he threw it all about I was like
oh wait that guy's wide open I was just
about to comment on the on the broadcast
that's what Donald's all about he's got
just playmates and abilities he's a
young Tony Romo meanwhile I I've seen
the highlights now on TV Dan and how
horrible it looks but feels level when
you're out there man that's a tough
position because it looked good and look
good for my perspective to Sam but no he
came over everybody was just quiet I
think a couple guys ottoman said don't
worry about it but this is the reason
why I was so high on Sam coming out of
USC you know he was on the US Army Bowl
which we broadcast on NBC every year
three years ago I was just so impressed
with his demeanor and how he handled
things I mean did I want a guy Dan that
committed to USC even though they
already had a verbal commitment from the
number one quarterback prospect in the
country Ricki town he just didn't care
he's not one of those guys that like had
a quarterback guru since eighth grade I
mean he played basketball he played
volleyball he only in 10th grade he
started like a linebacker and wide
receiver so I was talking we might
mckagan in the Jets Jim do you know that
this is only sand our old fifth year as
a starting quarterback not even I mean
he had two years in high school junior
senior and then at USC he had like a
year and a half because that Rose Bowl
year he only started the second half of
the year so he's 21 but he's also really
young in football years I didn't have
one of those quarterback gurus I think
he's only gonna get better from here and
what we've seen is he's definitely
unflappable because you know if I was 21
and I threw a pick six of my night
football at my first play there's no
I'm looking at the stands for my mom in
the over eight overreaction Department
who feels worse today about not drafting
Sam Darnell the Browns are the Giants
Giants Giants because for the Browns I
think they feel good about Baker
Mayfield and I think he's gonna be a
good player but for the Giants I mean
Dan you know I live in central
Pennsylvania I love steak well mark I
think he's a great player but we might
be hearing about this for 15 years I
mean he'll I did not look good to me and
you know the only reason why you make
the move was sake one is if you think
that eli has its work up more years you
might make a Super Bowl run I don't see
that happening
I think darlin I'm not saying that's
just based on one game this is how I
felt the whole time
I think Donald's gonna be a franchise
quarterback for 15 years so for the
Giants to pass on him when they've got
Eli up there in years I mean I'm not
even sure he lies that much better than
darling anymore right now I mean this is
that that is something that will be very
tough now you know who knows Dan maybe
in a couple years the Giants have a top
pick and they get a great quarterback
and and we don't talk about it but if
they don't if it's back to like the Kent
Graham Dave Brown days I mean Dave
gentlemen will never live it down
that'll be why he gets fired
good stuff Ross safe travels and we'll
talk to you soon
absolutely always great to be on thanks
for having me Ross Tucker Westwood one
sideline reported that last comment I
think deserves some headlines there that
Sam darn old might be as good as Eli
Manning right now week one overreaction
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]